Hey yeah did you send those to yourself
uh no I just remind Bobby to send it to
me okay what is it
the music oh I was just I was telling
you to text him to yourself so you had
all got to catch so if in case you
wanted to say you know go out with it
got Jungian anyway but if you ever Oh
Eric if you ever think about doing a
podcast yeah and you ever want to need
any kind of help you know we're here I
would love to I mean I've thought about
it a lot
honestly but I don't know what I would
talk about and I don't know what I would
do
Oliver Hudson and Kate Hudson you have
one now with they're dealing as siblings
one so my brother and I Steve and I did
one with Kate and Oliver oh they thought
it was really funny oh that's right but
so there that's what they are so they're
interviewing others you know celebrity
if I tell you what my idea is the
document is that then I have it and
nobody can do it yeah okay
so I've always wanted to do a podcast
where I wire my car up or I just buy a
car and wire it up as my podcast studio
and then we have a guest on we get in my
car and decide where we're going for
lunch you talk about what we're you know
the place we're going to what I have
what we're gonna eat then we take a
break and then go in and eat it and then
on the way home we just talked about
what we had and that's an interactions
that happen but it all takes place in
the car and at work not only could at
work not only could it work I think that
people would love it and also secondly
you know you injured I mean I know you
know I go to I still go to El Cholo
because of you because of me yeah
because you told me about the chicken
champion all my remember good I know but
remember like my favorite Mexican is
over by you now where you're gonna be
Tony's Mexican Grill really in cold
water what's Tony well you and I went
there for lunch no Tony's Mexican Grill
I'll get your exact coordinates and I'll
hook you up with good restaurants where
you're gonna be yeah I know a thing or
two because you know Jax does it right
that's Shepherd vodcast is great it's
great I heard it's Michael Roz Rosenbaum
has he is there's no room for more
podcast
oh it is and the beauty about podcasting
is that anyone can do it from anywhere
but the good ones will always sort of
rise job yeah it's like it's like
anything like I you know when I go on
the road now 90% of my audience is Tiger
belly fans so how many listeners do you
guys have right now how many people are
potentially a good amount
I think the difference there are
different kind of fan base because they
really latch on to the human part of you
they don't want to see a big performance
they don't want to see broadcasting
they're gonna be disappointed by this
then people like you know fumble on
their words yeah yeah like how I'm being
I'm sure see that's the other thing with
a podcast it's like you have it you have
the DNA and the past and track record
you can say whatever you want if I edit
myself so much in real life I can only
say what I want to say around a few
select people I understand your thing is
so dangerous man all right and I still
have to deal will edit the [ __ ] out of
this thing out of it but I have to even
because I see crazy [ __ ] well because
you have a conscience thing people
people don't know about you is that
you're you know or maybe they do but
you're a sweet guy he is sweet you're
sweet but he is he's very reckless with
some things that he says and he never
means it because because I didn't no one
gave me the memo that [ __ ] was bad
yeah you shouldn't say that yeah okay
this would be to be clipped all right
all right no don't say or that or [ __ ]
really can say yeah that little person
yeah you have to say little person I met
a little person comedian the other night
Factory I what too sad you know you
already know I met him it's like saying
well no this guy's gonna feel really bad
because it wasn't Brad it was some other
it was me forgot C's friend a little guy
you know who neighbor Gus yeah yeah I
know Nate but it's not Brad Williams no
Brad Williams is like super famous right
like yeah he's doing good yeah this guy
was not he's a [ __ ] no but can I say
something what I was watching Godzilla
the Matthew Broderick Godzilla one right
I mean is there anything more
stereotyped than that it's one of my
favorites okay the Matthew Broderick
Godzilla yeah oh the baby and what's his
name what was the camera man's name he
played I love him he's a good actor
anyway he's chasing after Godzilla
because he said he's a film like he
newscaster cameraman well who right I
wanna know who it is no his name is um
he's very good they gave us it come a
couple years ago didn't work but I like
look it up jean Reno no it wasn't Hank
Azaria yeah Hank you don't like them
yeah I love Hank Azaria but he's he's
more than how to sitcom a couple years
ago that didn't work I mean he's pretty
great alright that's facts I'm not you
know I just said I would like him a lot
yeah so he's running with the camera and
his girlfriend goes where you going
you're [ __ ] Yeah right and I remember
as a you know young man watching that
movie not having a problem with it 1998
yeah but they changed the rules what I'm
saying is it's it's not you who has a
problem with it of course you wouldn't
but if you have a family member who has
disabilities and things like that it
would it would hit you differently yeah
it would hit you the wrong way and I've
learned that by my beautiful girlfriend
who works with and my sister who works
with special needs and learning that and
you know as someone who i remember i was
telling tyler earlier that i remember a
bit he used to do and if we talked about
this and it's last one just cut this out
but yeah that a bit used to do where
people thought you were a special needs
person on the side of the right selling
corn oh yeah yeah yeah you still I still
have a version of that joke
you gotta let it go bro ya know let that
joke go no no no is it do it though
juice just just say corn the way you say
corn because that's what he cries are
expanding yeah but we know what if one
day like you know um this [ __ ] it's
like people say [ __ ] right and
that's wrong is it I don't know I don't
say anything when it comes to stuff cuz
I don't know what's correct because it's
not what the problem is is we've we've
we've switched to not wondering like
what's in the heart of a person carry
God we've just switched to words and
like nobody wants to I mean not nobody
but most people don't want to offend
other people but it comes from not it
just comes from not knowing which is
ignorance like an ignorance is not a bad
word when you when you it's in the right
context it's just that you don't know it
doesn't mean you're a racist person it
doesn't mean you're a bigoted person if
you are clearly just making a mistake in
semantics or words like yeah it's like
what Andrew Santino was in Japan mm-hmm
and he did that little thing with video
and you'd go to every Japanese pretty
girl Bobby Bobby Bobby right now if I
didn't know the guy Yeah right I'd be
like [ __ ] that guy right but you know I
know what is hard is and I make fun of
his red hair and his heritage
isn't that what true equality is what
everybody can be made fun of yes I rap
like no matter if you are in a
wheelchair or if you're like nobody has
a problem making fun of fat people still
though well I'll be real let's be real
honest about that fat people are still a
pretty simple easy target you can't
believe you know what one thing you
would be surprised by yeah you're fat -
[ __ ] yeah I know I don't care I
know I know and I love that about you
I don't have that I care I know I don't
think you do yes I do but do you know do
you want to know something that I think
you'll be really surprised by I don't
think I don't know if you've seen it or
not but how quickly because people just
assume oh you're on TV people recognize
you and know who you are all the time
that's not true
walk around and nobody at least to my
knowledge knows what what I do or who I
am or whatever who I think I am around
being on TV or what not yeah you know
what I mean but how quickly I can be in
Avon's parking lot and be like hey
you're you're parked a little close to
my car here like what a normal person
would do and how quickly that becomes
well yeah why don't you lose some weight
and you'd be able to get into it oh yeah
yeah you V you've been with him very
funny no we were we were a guy backed
into my car a guy completely backed into
my car he was in getting himself ice
cream it wasn't me yeah yes that's it no
no no I backed into my car and I just
get out of my car and I walk up next to
the car and I'm just like looking at him
like like this yeah he rolls down this
woman goes what's your [ __ ] problem
and I go is that how you roll through
life you just back into other people's
car and and don't do anything about it
so [ __ ] you you fat [ __ ] just
like goes off on me it's the reason why
now I have cameras on the front and back
of my cars interactions oh because that
guy could have easily had just
apologized oh don't you want he's my
going to in those kind of circumstances
want to get recognized right then and
there though no I don't I know in any
part of it because I go red like you
know my situation
and so I have to I've gone way I backed
away away from so people just out of
just their immediate response is to make
fun of someone's way of course but I'm
no different than anyone else like in
that in that aspect I'm glad I'm able to
like say like yeah I know what happens
because it happens to me so imagine just
the I've seen it happen before with
people but anyway my point is there is
like we're putting making this whole
list of what we can and can't say let's
let's start adding fat people to the
list we will is that we judge ourselves
by our intentions but we judge others by
mere words and actions like we always
say oh I'm not a bigot I'm not this
because
no our personal intentions right but
well we judge others by we never stop to
think about what their intention is we
only just hear words yeah your actions
and that's it we like react based on
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]